it takes a tough breed to hack a living
from the searing hot inhospitable Amazon
region they come to rear cattle and to
plant soil yams and much else besides
they do so legally but are vulnerable in
this huge poorly police region to
illegal speculators they are grabbing
all of that area part of the Gemara
Nature Reserve they're grabbing
everything and the word is they will cut
everything down if they do then they'll
set it on fire this man said he feared
for his life if his identity was
revealed say neither the police nor the
authorities have the resources to
protect him from neighbors who covered
his land just when the president is
being called upon to do more by the
international community and some of
those living here to do more to defend
the Amazon he moves in the opposite
direction he invites more development
which many living here feel will put
both the environment and themselves a
greater risk president balsa Naro says
too much of this forest is protected
neither nature reserves or indigenous
reservations that poverty awaits those
who don't take advantage but this
rancher said he thought there had been
enough deforestation the Amazon has to
have cattle we don't need to divorce
anything else though just take care of
the lands that are already deforested
take care of the rivers of the springs
cattle is what we live from however he
said he doesn't blame the president for
the land grabs all the fires he believes
the region is simply too big to police
despite the efforts of the local
authorities and a criminally - crime
happens everywhere however our policies
have been positive so far but because of
the size of this state and the way its
land is occupied our policies will take
time to work to guarantee security in
both urban and rural areas other small
farmers stressed that farming can and
should only be done in a sustainable way
some people don't respect the law and
this creates a bad image of our country
abroad but we keep fighting for local
farmers who work with nature the
ecosystem so that we could all survive
the battle for land has been raging
since the arrival of the first Europeans
the dream that in his vast country there
is enough for everyone often shattered
by greed corruption and poor management
Daniel Shriner al-jazeera rondonia state
northwestern Brazil